والدول النووية على ايقاف صنع
السلاح النووي. وقد وقعت جميع
تصنيع السلاح النووي محظورا
عالميا. وخير دليل ما يحدث
الولايات المتحدة فقد اجرت
الامارات صفقاتها العسكرية مع
العرب ذلك? وهل يسمح الغرب
والامريكان بامتلاك العرب لهذا
العسكرية بين الامارات وبيونج
يانج الى عام تسعة وثمانين في
عشر. وتضيف التقارير ان كوريا
الشمالية تعتبر موردا محتملا
علاقات سرية بين ابو ظبي وكوريا
الشمالية. كشفت مذكرة وزارة
في فلسطين. اسرائيل هي من قصفت
مفاعل العراق النووي. فهل يعي
وباكستان هذه الاخبار. الخيار
الثاني التخلص من الاسلحة
العاصمة حيث كانت قدرته خمسة عشر
ميجا وات بالماء الثقيل وكان
نووي سعودي. الامارات عام الفين
وخمسة عشر ظهرت تقارير امريكية
وقع في مفاعل جعل العالم يشك في
المحطات النووية المصرية. لذا تم
العاصمة الرياض تحتوي على صواريخ
نووية بينما نفت السعودية
عام الفين وثلاثة. خرجت مصادر
تؤكد ان السعودية تملك ثلاثة
وماذا سيحدث للعالم لو امتلكت
السعودية والعرب سلاحا نوويا في
كثيرا من السياسيين اكدوا ان
السعودية تمتلك اسلحة نووية
الصواريخ النووية والرؤوس
الحربية عرضت المجلة صورا
العربية السعودية. لا تملك
المملكة برنامج اسلحة نووية. لكن
كما تمتلك العديد من الاسلحة
المتطورة لكن ماذا عن السلاح
السابق معمر القذافي عن مكونات
اسلحته النووية التي كانت في
الثقيل وهو خاضع لمراقبة الوكالة
الدولية للطاقة بينما تسعى
للاقمار الصناعية تكشف عن مدينة
تحت الارض في مدينة السريل جنوبي
كرير. الفرصة الثانية فكرت مصر
مرة ثانية في احياء برنامجها
المرتبة الثالثة عربيا والثانية
افريقيا من حيث التسلح. المملكة
تلبي احتياجات مصر المستقبلية من
الطاقة وتعوض نقص احتياطاتها
اليوم الا ان حرب سبعة وستين
اخفقت مشروع انشاء محطة سيدي
فكانت اول محطة في العالم ذات
استخدام مزدوج لتوليد الكهرباء
الجزائر صفقات كبيرة لشراء
الاسلحة خاصة مع روسيا جعلتها في
المصري مشاكل كثيرة تتعلق
بالتدخل الدولي المتزايد في
جديد العمل على تعديل اتفاقيتها
مع وزارة الطاقة الامريكية لرفع
الثالثة في عام واحد وثمانين.
عرض خبراء الطاقة في مصر على
ثلاث وثمانين وقعت الجزائر
والصين اتفاقية سرية تقوم
الامريكية للامداد بالوقود
النووي اللازم للمحطة. الفرصة
يستخدم اليورانيوم المخصب
المنخفض وقادرا على انتاج بين
ستمائة ميجاوات الى اربعة الاف
ميجاوات. الا ان الانفجار الذي
اتخاذ القرار الدولي. فلو كانت
احدى الدول العربية قد صنعته قبل
كوريا الشمالية من خلال شركات
خاصة لضمان عدم خضوع ابو ظبي
امتلاك صدام السلاح النووي
حينها. فهو الذي اطلق عليهم تسعة
العرب ونفس يحدث الان من
اغتيالات للعلماء النوويين
العالم العربي ويعني بالضرورة
تراجع المحتل الاسرائيلي وردعه
لا يجعلها دولة نووية لربما يكون
هناك تبادل في الخبرات مستقبلا
والخلاصة فذلك القرار ينص ان
النووية حلال لهم وحرام على
بقيمة مائة مليون دولار من كوريا
الشمالية في يونيو الفين وخمسة
الخدمة منذ عام الف وتسعمائة
وثلاثة وتسعين. ويعمل بالماء
في مرحلة بدائية. وعام الفين
وثلاثة تخلى الزعيم الليبي
اما في عام واحد وثمانين قصفت
اسرائيل المفاعل بنفسها وسببت
النووية. تأتي مصر في المرتبة
الاولى عسكريا في الوطن العربي
الرئيس السادات تطوير البرنامج
النووي من جديد عن طريق انشاء
الدولية خوفا من استخدامها سرا
من قبل الجزائريين. كان البرنامج
العراق عضوا في الوكالة الدولية
للطاقة الذرية واستطاع بذلك
البترولية. ثم وقعت مصر اتفاقا
مع لجنة الطاقة النووية
النووي كان لمصر ثلاث فرص لتنفيذ
برنامجها النووي الفرصة الاولى
الدول لمنع ايران من اكمال
برنامجها لكن ليس معلوما ان كانت
الحصول على عقد بين بغداد لانشاء
محطة الكهروموية لتوليد
النووي بعد حرب ثلاثة وسبعين حيث
قررت اقامة ثماني محطات نووية
وثلاثين صاروخا باليستيا دون
تردد. فماذا لو امتلك النووي في
مرحلة بدائية ايضا وتم تسليمها
للولايات المتحدة الامريكية. مصر
اضرارا كبيرة. بل اسرائيليون
يعلمون الخطر قد يواجههم حال
سرعان ما قام الامريكيون بكل شيء
للحد من انتشار الاسلحة النووية
اذ يعلن قانون ماك ماهون الذي
عدل عند ازدياد التوتر مع
وتسعمائة وستين حتى الف وتسعمائة
وستة وستين. وقد اسفرت عن عدد
لتطوير مفاعله النووي الذي كان
يسمى حينها مفاعل تموز كان
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين والهند
وباكستان واسرائيل وكوريا
يمتلكون لماذا السعودية ومصر
والعراق والجزائر والامارات
فرنسا سبع عشرة تجربة نووية في
الجزائر في الفترة من الف
الارض صحراء لا تصلح الزراعة ولا
العيش ولن يكون فيها اي من مظاهر
وبقية الدول العربية لا يمتلكون
هذا السلاح؟ اليك الجواب؟ ابادت
المتعلقة بالطاقة النووية صنفت
كسرية ويحظر استخدامها في
الحياة وهناك مدن مهجورة بسبب
تسرب الاشعاعات النووية فاجرها
البشر والحيوانات وتركوها خالية
يا لهذا السلاح الخبيث. اجرت
البشر. الكثير من الاطفال
والنساء وكبار السن سينتهي كل
القنبلة النووية مات الكثير من
الناس. ولا زالت اثارها الى هذه
القنبلة. القها. هيا القها. يا
سيدي لا استطيع سيموت الكثير من
السلاح الخارق
حين ان شراء مواد نووية كبيرة من
كوريا الشمالية سيواجه معارضة من
توقيع الات لكانت الان من ضمن
الدول النووية. ولهذا السبب اصبح
المنطقة والعالم ويعني انهاء
الوصاية الامريكية والغربية على
لايران وكوريا الشمالية من
عقوبات في وقتنا الراهن.
وحاربوا صدام والجزائر ومصر.
واغتالوا جميع العلماء النوويين
برنامجا نوويا سعوديا على
اراضيها اعلن رئيس الاستخبارات
خيارات حول الاسلحة النووية.
الخيار الاول ان تتحالف مع دولة
الجزائر غير ان هذه المساعي
الاسرائيلية زادت بعد ابرام
مارس الفين وستة ذكرت مجلة
المانية ان السعودية تلقت
السعودية السابق الامير تركي
الفيصل بانه اذا امتلكت ايران
الدول على حظر هذا السلاح
باستثناء الدول التي امتلكته قبل
مخالفة امريكا ولن تجرؤ على تحمل
العقوبات الامريكية. عملت امريكا
لايران. امتلاك العرب للسلاح
النووي يعني تعديل التوازنات في
غيرهم باتفاقيات دولية. ولهذا
ايضا افشلوا سلاح القذافي
العاصمة الجزائرية بواسطة
الاقمار الصناعية لتبدأ حملة
سريا للغاية الى حين نشر واشنطن
تايمز تقريرا يوم عشر من ابريل
تملك اسلحة نووية كي تحميها كما
تفعل السعودية مع باكستان. في
وتحلية مياه البحر بطاقة تعمل
بمعدل عشرين الف متر مكعب في
عام واحد وتسعين عن اكتشاف
امريكا مفاعلا نوويا جنوب
القرارات الدولية. فالدول
المذكورة قد صنعت النووية قبل
النووية في الشرق الاوسط. اما
الخيار الثالث امتلاك برنامج
ولا تزال تلك المناطق المخصصة
للاختبار تشكل هاجسا للمجموعة
والمال الاماراتي مقابل النووي
الكوري. لكن الامارات لا تستطيع
للعقوبات الامريكية. لكن تقارب
ابو ظبي مع مجنون كوريا الشمالية
الداخل بدعوى الرقابة على
انشطتها ماذا عن الجزائر? سنة
تستطيع المملكة مواجهة جميع
الضغوطات الغربية وصناعة نووية
اثراء اليورانيوم الضروري لتشغيل
المحطات النووية المصرية من
دولية ضد الجزائر من اجل اجبارها
على التوقيع على معاهدة عدم
عام واحد وتسعين بدأ العراق
تفكيك برنامجه النووي الذي كان
صينية وتمول برنامج اسلحة نووية
في باكستان وتحاول ايضا ان تبني
الغاء المشروع. اما اليوم فتواجه
عملية احياء البرنامج النووي
ثلاث الى خمسة كيلو جرامات من
البلوتونيوم. تعتبر الجزائر
اسلحة نووية فان السعودية سوف
تمتلك اسلحة نووية ايضا فهل
الاحتلال الفرنسي. حيث تم القيام
بسبع عشرة تجربة نووية تحت الارض
على مفاعل تموز. لكن هذه الغارة
لم تكن ذات فاعلية كبيرة ولم
بيرين وكان هذا المفاعل اكبر من
المفاعل الاول بالدراري الجزائر
بموجبها الصين بتجهيز الجزائر
بمفاعل نووي تم بناؤه بمنطقة
الدولة الافريقية الوحيدة التي
تعرضت للتجارب النووية ابان
انتشار الاسلحة النووية. ودخل
المفاعل الذي يسمى بالسلام
للمواد النووية لدولة الامارات
العربية المتحدة وتعود الروابط
اسرائيل باستخدام الاقمار
الصناعية للتجسس على مفاعلات
تعترف بامتلاكها تلك الاسلحة
رسميا وهي روسيا وامريكا
مقدمتها العراق الذي شرع في
تطوير مفاعله النووي خلال فترة
الكهرباء. خلال ذلك عام تسعة
وسبعين. نفذت ايران غارة جوية
ايران تمتلك رؤوسا نووية ام لا.
بينما في الدول العربية وياتي في
حكم صدام حسين مستعينا بالاتحاد
السوفيتي. ثم تعاونت معه فرنسا
ومنذ عام الف وتسعمائة وستة
واربعين تنظم واشنطن هذه المسألة
ثماني محطات نووية قدرة كل منها
الف ميجاوات. حيث بدأت مصر من
امريكا مدينتين يابانيتين عام
الف وتسعمائة وخمسة واربعين لكن
الاتحاد السوفيتي واعلان الحرب
الباردة ان جميع البيانات
عام ثلاثة وستين حين انشأت اول
محطة نووية في منطقة سيدي كرير
الشمالية. لماذا لا يمتلكه
العرب? تقف امريكا في مقدمة
تسبب اضرارا بالغة حيث احتاج
المفاعل شهرين فقط ليتم اصلاحه.
الخارجية الامريكية التي تم
تسريبها ان الامارات اشترت اسلحة
تؤكد ان الامارات تسعى لامتلاك
سلاح نووي. تسريبات امريكية تكشف
الصناعة الخاصة اذ ارادت
الولايات الحفاظ على تقدمها. في
العالم هناك تسع دول تمتلك اسلحة
نووية بعضها يعترف بذلك واخرى لا
اثارها الى اليوم. لكن لماذا
يمتلك الغرب سلاحا نوويا ولا
تمتلكه الدول العربية ولماذا
العرب لا يصنعون هذا السلاح ولا
غير محدد من الضحايا بين سبعة
وعشرين الفا ومائة الف وما زالت
اللحظات. ان هذا السلاح يبخر
الاجساد والحجر والشجر. ويرجع
شيء. القها بامر من القيادة
العليا. ارمها حالا. وعند القاء
الطائرة تحلق فوق هيروشيما.
القائد يأمر الجندي ان يرمي